[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number
195 I'm Dr Brett Weinstein I'm of course
sitting with Dr Heather hying we are
trying an experiment we are broadcasting
for the first time live on the platform
formerly known as Twitter so that is an
interesting experiment I um hope it
works well and we will figure out what
exactly to do with it I will ask people
a couple of things before we get moving
here one is uh we are broadcasting on my
account uh for various reasons but I
would ask you to sign up for our podcast
account the handle is the Dark Horse pod
so that's on Twitter please just sign up
for it that way you will see uh future
materials that we broadcast here and I
would would also ask you to sign up for
our channel on Rumble and check out our
community on locals people often ask us
how they can support us and there are a
lot of ways to support us which we will
talk about here in a second but these
are things that you can do that actually
do have a material benefit they make it
easier for us to function in the world
and they cost you nothing so um please
sign up for those two things uh if you
don't choose to do something else
appreciate it all right so here we are
on Twitter we're on Rumble we're on
YouTube uh watch party is live on locals
and also I guess for your subscribers on
Twitter uh there's chat no not happening
at all okay we're learning folks it's a
live fire
exercise not sure that's the right um
wrong week for that yeah that's the
wrong it's the wrong week for that um so
we're we're doing this today we're going
to have two more live streams uh com
coming up um Dark Horse live streams
evolutionary lens coming up on Saturday
and again on Tuesday and then we're
taking a Hiatus um but we're also having
a private Q&A this weekend through local
so lots of places to uh to to see what
we're talking about in the next week and
then there will be some wonderful guest
podcasts coming out uh while we're on
live stream
Hiatus um I think maybe we'll just jump
right into the ads our sponsors we
always have three sponsors at the top of
the hour so let us just say we have to
pay the rent uh our predicament means
that in order for us to do what we do
paying the rent is just simply something
that has to happen and ads are
absolutely required for that to be the
case so let us do that and then we'll
get to the the heart of the matter we
have three sponsors as always whom we
choose carefully the top of the hour uh
we encourage you to to visit them they
are this week Arma uh um actually no
that's mine sorry Arma MD hearing it and
American Heartford gold somewhat out of
order here we go our first sponsor this
week is ancient it's AR AR ra Arma is
colostrum colostrum is the first food
that every mammal eats produced in the
first two or three days of an infant's
life and is nutritionally different from
the milk that comes in afterwards
mammals have existed for over 300
million years give or take a few tens of
millions of years and the first food
every mammal has eaten is colostrum
colostrum serves many vital functions
including that of protecting and
strengthening the mucosal barriers of
infants before their own barriers mature
modern living breaks down your mucosal
and immune barriers and armor is the
superfood that builds it back armor
colostrum protects and s your body's
barriers creating a seal that guards
against inflammation everyday toxins
pollutants and threats armor uses their
cold chain biop potent technology to
concentrate colostrums 400 plus living
nutrients into their most pure and
bioavailable form according to a review
published in the journal clinical
nutrition open science in 2022 bovine
colostrum has been used to treat cancer
AIDS polio heart disease and rheumatoid
arthritis it is a general
anti-inflammatory and it's use in adults
is known to increase lean muscle mass
improve athletic performance and
recovery time support healthy digestion
and reduce allergy symptoms armor starts
with sustainably Source colostrum from
grass-fed cows from their Co-op of dairy
farms in the US and they Source only the
Surplus colostrum after calves are fully
fed unlike most colostrums which use
heat pasteurization that depletes
nutrient potency armor uses their cold
chain biop poent technology an
Innovative process that purifies and
preserves the Integrity of hundreds of
bioactive nutrients while removing
cassine and fat to guarantee the highest
potency of any colostrum available on
the market the quality control is far
above industry standards which is always
good because industry standards tend to
be low uh including being certified to
be glyphosate free benefits of armor
colostrum also include clearing of
blemishes shinier thicker hair
stabilization of blood sugar levels and
acceleration of fat burning and
colostrum has been shown to
significantly improve Fitness endurance
and significantly decrease recovery time
after intense exercise armor has a
special offer for the Dark Horse
audience receive 15% off your first
order go to tr arm.com Darkhorse or
enter Darkhorse to get 15% off your
first order once more that's t R ym
r.com
Darkhorse and as always my favorite ad
reads this one I have a footnote you
have a footnote reference yeah I once
wrote a poem with a footnote I know um
it was a good footnote I mean it was a
good poem I it was one of very few good
poems I've written but it was it was
good
yeah our second sponsor this week is MD
hearing we have friends and family who
have hearing loss there a good chance
that you do too well we don't have need
for hearing aids ourselves we have a
good friend who does we asked her to
assess MD hearing's newest product
carefully and honestly her testimonial
is at the end of this ad MD hearing
makes high quality simple and effective
hearing aids for a tiny fraction of what
what most hearing aids cost helping
bring audio Clarity and capacity to
people who might not otherwise be able
to afford it MD hearing was founded by
an ENT surgeon who made it his mission
to develop a quality hearing aid that
anyone could afford he kept the price
Low by removing several rarely needed
components MD hearings Neo model costs
over 90% less than Clinic hearing aids
and the Neo is MD hearing's smallest
hearing a ever it fits inside your ear
and no one will know it's there MD
hearings products have also have
rechargeable batteries that last up to
30 hours and their volt plus model is
water resistant in up to three feet of
water you don't need a prescription
which also means there's no
middleman you know when I first read
that three feet of water I thought well
that's not very much on the other hand
um you're probably not listening to much
when you're in water anyway so that
three feet of water is supposed to um
protect you if you end up going into
water without meaning to with your
hearing aids yeah it's air amount of
water actually it's not the deep end but
it it's the shallow end indeed um here's
the newest testimonial from our friend
who a substantial hearing loss and who
relies on hearing aids we asked her to
try this product and this is what she
said I tested the Neo MD hearings new in
the ear canal hearing aids I was a bit
skeptical since I've never liked in the
ear canal models preferring the
stability of over-the-ear sets they were
surprisingly comfortable and stable
staying put without coming loose even
when I wore them to exercise I tried the
Neo in several situations she writes
from Discord voice chat to an inperson
conversation in a room with a white
noise generator and they passed every
test while it's true they don't have the
individual audiogram programming and
smartphone integration of my usual
hearing aids they have everything else
for less than 5% of the price they
provide an absolutely stunning level of
quality for pennies on the dollar so if
you want MD hearing smallest hearing a
ever go to MD hearing.com and use promo
code Darkhorse to get their new $297
when you buy a pair offer head to MD
hearing.com and use promo code darkar to
get their brand new $297 when you buy a
pair offer it's a fa deal for a fabulous
product okay uh two notes before I get
to the final ad uh if you hear me
crunching in the background I am fending
off a cough from a case of what must
have been coid 3 weeks ago uh that I got
better from almost immediately but the
cough will not let me uh let me uh live
a normal life so anyway hopefully we'll
get past that but anyway the crunching
is
unavoidable um also point out for people
watching us on Twitter uh we as Heather
said only back uh Spa sponsors we reject
numerous sponsors and we only back
things that we believe in the green
outline on the screen does tell you
though that we are speaking um as a
result of a financial Arrangement and
that means when it's gone you don't have
to worry that we are because we aren't
we're speaking for ourselves okay our
final sponsor is American Heart for gold
if you listen to Darkhorse regularly
then you know just how incompetent and
unstable many of our institutions are
becoming interest rates are Skyhigh we
are caught between runaway inflation and
recession we are assured that this is
all fine while the cost of food housing
Medical Care schools everything climbs
which you've noticed if you uh ever
enjoy housing or food our leaders are
increasingly nonsensical all of this
threatens businesses jobs and retirement
funds finding ways to secure your nest
egg and insulate your wealth is more
important than ever and adding precious
metals to your assets is a great way to
stabilize your Investments and protect
yourself financially American Heart for
gold is a precious metals dealer that
can help you do just that American
Hartford gold helps individuals and
families protect their wealth by
diversifying with precious metals they
make it simple and easy to protect your
savings and retirement accounts with
physical gold and silver with one short
phone call they can have physical gold
and silver delivered right to your door
or inside your IRA or 401K they are the
highest rated firm in the country with
an A+ rating from the Better Business
Bureau and thousands of satisfied
clients and if you call them right now
they will give you up to $5,000 in free
silver on your first qualifying order
contact them today by visiting the link
in the episode descript description or
call
8668281166
8281 1117 or text Darkhorse to
98899 again 866 82811109
8899 all right ads
finished all
right I do not know what the world looks
like to other people I will say
there has been a lot of talk on Twitter
X about the important difference between
what those of us who use that platform
are seeing and what people who use other
platforms or pay attention to the
mainstream media are seeing with respect
to the conflict in the Middle East um
there's a lot to say about it there is
certainly a huge amount of noise being
circulated on X it is not like a uh
refined portrait of anything there's
lots of garbage but but what is being
noticed by many people is that one does
seem to have access to the signal buried
in that noise there's lots of actual
evidence emerging on on Twitter X and we
are able to sort through it and sorting
really is the key to understanding where
we are
so we have been looking at this
unfolding picture in Israel as a result
of the attacks on Israel
uh on October 7th and yesterday I
recorded and we released uh on the same
day a uh a podcast with an Israeli
journalist she's a freelancer who also
um served in the IDF as all Israelis do
25 years ago and she served on the Gaza
border um this is ifrat fenon and the um
podcast hased produced a very intense
reaction uh most of it extremely
positive people including I've seen
there's lots of public stuff you can
look at the reactions publicly and
there's a tremendous outpouring of
gratitude for a perspective that is not
widely being discussed elsewhere but
there's also a concerted amount of push
back of an interesting kind which we
will talk a little bit about um and then
there is the behind the scenes uh
responses that that I have received and
I know uh ifrat has also received from
people some of them very well-positioned
very careful thinkers who have reacted
universally positively to this pod ah
universally positively with one
exception I did get one um push back
from somebody I I quite respect in any
case we are going to talk today
about
um the predicament in the Middle East
about the implication in The Wider World
which I believe we have no choice but to
discuss even though in some ways this
event uh for forces us to narrow our
Focus or it it attempts to force us to
narrow our focus and um this is none of
this is easy to do and so maybe the
maybe the thing to do is
to just surface what I think is the
underlying fundamental tension that uh
causes even an exploration between two
people both of whom uh one of whom I
know for certain is acting in good faith
and attempting to do what he thinks is
right and another person who I believe
to be doing exactly the same thing but
can't know for sure because it's not me
um you want to jump in just that um you
I was not present for your conversation
with afrat um but I listened to it
afterwards and uh you know we we spend a
lot of time together we spend a lot of
time listening to each other and uh I
don't generally listen to the guest
episodes of Dark Horse because there's
just only so many hours in the day and
you know we we are already in each
other's heads quite quite enough yep
um this one I felt was important to
listen to and expected to just have to
do it uh it it wasn't a burden at all uh
it's it's extraordinarily powerful and
real and human human and um you know
really you know we're scheduled to be on
live right now and it just it feels
honestly like a bit of a mistake like
I'd like to just encourage people to go
and listen to you and a fra talking um
you know which is which is up on on the
rumble Channel and the and the YouTube
channel and Spotify and everywhere um
it's it's an extraordinary conversation
and one of the kinds of push back that
I've seen has been um but she's not an
intelligent
expert yeah and you know she never
claims to be right there and and this is
also this is also the nature of much of
the criticism I'm seeing you know I I
put I published a tiny little thing um
just behind my substack pay wall on on
Israel yesterday um and some of the push
back I got was you you don't know
anything you know you're not an expert
you're not
Jewish okay you
know all you know except for that you
don't know any anything you know didn't
claim to be an expert specifically said
I don't know all what to think um but
this is barbarism I don't know that I I
don't remember that I used that word in
the um in the piece but um you know
calling out Hamas is a terrorist
organization um is um remarkably getting
a ton of push back so I'm going to U
pursue this a little bit um I think for
those many of the people watching this
have undoubtedly seen the conversation
with ifrat went out on uh on Twitter so
uh the overlap in the audience is is
substantial for those who haven't I
think this conversation will work
perfectly well as a prequel in some
sense we will talk about the predicament
of having a conversation and then you
can watch the conversation and I think
it will uh only enhance it let me lay
out the fundamental problem and mind you
I feel that the Peril of even talking
about this is profound and I could be
totally wrong about that it could be
that there's no Peril at all and that
this is just normal uh push back and
that there's no real danger beyond the
simple danger that a companies uh
attempting to sort out the truth in a
contentious moment or it's possible that
there is actual real Peril um and we're
not going to know uh but here's the
problem as described in the podcast and
as you and I have talked about many
times on Darkhorse and as we have talked
about elsewhere we've talked about it in
our book The Hunter Gathers Guide to the
21st
century um there is a tension between
two possible modes of interaction that
we humans can engage in one of them
whether I have the terminology
defensively correct or not I would call
the west and the thing that I believe is
at the core of the idea of the West is
that we put aside our lineage
membership um you might take take that
as a shorthand for race race is
a uh a broken term for reasons we won't
go into here but lineage would be the
responsible biological way to talk about
such things a population being the
living portion of a lineage the lineage
being the whole thing stretching uh
backward into history and forward
potentially into the future it is an
individual and all of their living
descendants and the humans are one
lineage we have a most recent common
ancestor and so one way to view the
world is by that lineage but there are
many many sublineages right down to you
and all your surviving uh descendants
that's a tiny little lineage so there is
one way to view our uh relationships to
each other that puts lineage aside and I
will say what that means it does not
mean abandoning your family it does not
mean pretending that your history isn't
what it is it doesn't mean giving up
your Traditions but it means not playing
a game in which lineages have structural
advantages over other
lineages right it means a Level Playing
Field in which uh you choose who to
partner with um based on who has
something that they bring to the table
that is worth partnering with and you do
not seek to rig the game in favor of
your people okay now I believe that this
is the only viable future for the Earth
there was a version of the earth I will
call it the Old Testament version of the
earth which is lineage based I don't
think the Old Testament that in that
context there was any choice about it
anybody who opted out of lineage versus
lineage competition was going to W be
wiped out by people who didn't and so in
the past there was no choice now I
believe we are in the opposite
predicament if we fall back in into
lineage versus lineage competition and
we've never completely escaped it but if
we fall back into it with modern
technology including modern Weaponry I
don't believe that Humanity can actually
survive through it so let me just lay
out some
values that I hold that I know I share
with you that you will see if you view
it from these two lenses create a
terrible unresolvable
problem okay I am a believer in the
west I believe that we are all dependent
on this Western notion or an upgraded
version of it coming to dominate the way
we interact over the planet and that we
we exist in basically two camps with
respect to
that I am a
patriot I will
actually fight and die for my country
and more importantly for the West I
believe that my country uh if
effectively sparked the modern West and
that that is an idea on which we are so
dependent that it is actually it is a
hill worth literally dying on if need
be I will also say I am
Jewish I am in no way ashamed of this I
don't know whether it is appropriate to
be proud of that though I am proud of
many things that exist in Jewish culture
which I believe are inscribed deeply
into me and I have no ambiguity
whatsoever on whether or not the Jewish
people are entitled to survive and
thrive on planet Earth I believe Israel
has a right to exist and I would fight
and I would die to keep it in existence
what I will not do is lift a finger to
provide advantage to any lineage over
any other lineage I'm not saying I would
not work through Merit to produce
advantages but I do not want any
structural Advantage for any lineage I
don't want anybody displacing anybody
else now the problem is on the one hand
if you view that set of values from a
western mindset that is a mindset that
has already accepted that we should
partner with people irrespective of
their phenotype and the implication that
it carries for what genes they have in
their
genomes then this may seem obvious
if on the other hand you view it through
an Old Testament lens it may seem like a
betrayal I don't believe there's
anywhere you can stand that actually
allows you to embrace the values that
allow Humanity to continue going
forward
without committing this
betrayal according to the old
rules now I don't know what to do about
that I don't like the idea that in a
world where the West is actually falling
AP part and we are being dragged back
into the Old Testament rules I have to
commit
myself uh to a betrayal of them but
nonetheless it is where I find myself
and I believe in some sense we are all
caught in this bind and so let me say
something very clear about the events in
Israel and what they mean I um yeah
please uh play Devil's out here for a
moment absolutely um one thing I heard
you say at the end of your explanation
of which I'm well familiar with of why
um what you're calling Old Testament
values in Counterpoint to the West uh
should not be allowed to Triumph was and
I believe this is a quote I don't want
anyone to displace anyone
else that seems
naive you know there are the planet is
limited we have finite resources
uh and and history is
long
and you know one thing that is true of
course uh is that um different waves of
people have existed in places and so
claims of land rights are often
legitimately confused because two people
two peoples two populations two lineages
if you will uh actually truly do feel
like this is their
land and uh you know the the game that
many on
the pseudo left I I don't even know what
to call them the the game that many play
um around things like First
Peoples um is only the first inhabitants
of a space have rights and this is naive
and silly right this is a sort of this
is the same mistake that frankly ecology
makes like the moment that we decide
that this is the thing that we like
that's the thing that we will preserve
not before then not after then and
there's sort of an illusion of the
falseness of the claim by calling it
first peoples but the first peoples are
almost never first how could we don't
right so um by starting the clock on
Israel at say
1940 um it can appear uh that there was
a that there was a land grab um if you
start the clock um at many earlier
points in history uh it is clear um that
um people who are in the lineage of the
Jewish Israelis um were actually there
um with with rights to to land first um
so you know again your your argument I
don't I don't want anyone to displace
anyone
else with with finite Resources with
finite land there will be displacement
okay so let me address all those um and
this will none of this will be new to
you because you've you've you've heard
how I think about this over the course
of of many years
the first thing to say is when I say
nobody should displace
anybody um there is a completely
arbitrary agreement that we must start
the clock at approximately now that if
we attempt to relitigate history there
is no stopping point and it just simply
can't be done there is no solution that
looks like that which does not mean that
you won't have um Grievances unaddressed
and in fact uh uh you know I'm I'm a
European Jew by extraction it's not how
I grew up I grew up very much as an
American and it's how I uh feel but my
people are all European Jews they were
massively
displaced I have friends in all of the
populations that did the displac him and
we will get to the meaning of that soon
but the point is I am not looking to
relitigate even recent history even with
respect to my own lineage and you know
do I like that no but I just know that
if there's no solution down a path then
going down the path is not sensible and
I'm not saying there's never anything to
be done there are things to be done and
I hope they will be done but but anyway
here's the fundamental problem with
displacement you and I know that
ultimately displacement is about
something
absurd the proximate part of it is not
the proximate part part of it is the
life and death struggles of people right
and that is the important part but what
selection is doing through us is it is
attempting to take spellings of your
genes and Lodge them as deeply in the
future as it can
and I cannot
articulate just how insane that is from
the point of view of a person with
actual values because literally Lally
the following thing is
true if I have a gene or a respiratory
enzyme and another person has a
different spelling of the same gene my
Gene at any costs would like to displace
that competitor Gene even if the
competitor Gene is superior at doing the
job of the enzyme in the environment
where the individual has landed or or
even universally evolution is not about
the beauty of what these genes
accomplish it is about the simple fact
that spellings that drive other
spellings to Extinction tend to be the
spellings that we see yeah it's it it is
in your language inherently Old
Testament it is inherently Old Testament
and it is completely absurd I have used
the analogy of a cosmic spelling be that
ends in genocide right people will
literally kill each other over genes
that they didn't know existed 200 years
ago
and they don't know that they're doing
it they think they're doing it for
reasons of ideology or reasons of those
people are unforgivable and whatever it
may be and so anyway when I say nobody
should displace anybody I don't mean
that there's not going to be EB and flow
of how many of each type of person there
is and I don't mean that those things
don't have consequences what I mean is
that when people become committed to the
idea that they have a right to X and
that those other people don't and that's
why they're going to rig the system to
for this that and the
they're operating on a program they're
not even aware of an evolutionary
program that is completely amoral so
anyway now I do have to say there's
another
way our longtime listeners will have
heard me talk about the fact that there
are certain times in which it makes
perfect sense to intellectualize
questions and parse them as carefully as
possible and talk about them and I have
specifically discussed the fact of a
hunting party that goes out in need of
resources for the tribe and a fighting
force that goes out into battle and the
terrible danger posed by somebody who
walks onto a battlefield and starts
intellectualizing it is not the place
for it and I am aware that one
interpretation of what I am doing and
what we are doing is that we are doing
we are making exactly that error at a
moment of perfect historical Clarity we
are muddying the waters with ual stuff
that has to be sidelined until the
affront that has just occurred has been
addressed I do not believe that's where
we are if I did believe that that's
where we are I wouldn't do it I would
not be that person so if I am making an
error it is an honest error I am I am
intellectualizing here because I believe
that our future as a species depends on
us doing it at this exact moment because
we are going to be dragged into a
paradigm from which There Is No Escape
if we do not figure out exactly where we
are and why to the best of our
ability um so I do need to make a clear
statement about what took place the
Hamas attack on Southern Israel was so
unambiguously and intentionally barbaric
that there is no Nuance to be had about
the people who conducted it these people
are they have begged to be wiped off the
face of the Earth for the safety of the
rest of us and I believe that that
should absolutely
happen the problem is these people
that's meaning that's the point when I
say these people I mean the people who
actually made the decisions to do that
and the they have tactically embedded
themselves in a population that has a
variance in opinion about those attacks
there are those who didn't participate
in them who fully believe in them
they have a status that is not quite
that of the people who committed the
crimes but it is not innocent and then
there are to be certain a great many
people who are innocent either because
they would not have done this if they
had had the decision-making power and
more to the point whatever else is true
there are children those children are
Innocent by definition they are not old
enough to have understood what is taking
place enough to make a wise judgment so
we are stuck with the fact that you have
a terrorist organization wielding
barbarism in order to make sure that
there is no choice in the response and
embedded in a population that is going
to be um devastated that guarantees that
the response will in turn hurt civilians
right and I believe and as as I said on
Twitter and as I wrote In Salon in 2015
after the Charlie hebo attack um that
this is the point of terrorism the point
of terrorism is not to harm your enemy
it is to induce your enemy to harm
itself um and so I believe that uh
whatever else is true Israel
was put in a predicament that is a trap
that the only response it can make is
inherently a response that will I don't
know what the net effect will be but
will have severely negative effects on
the way people view the state of
Israel that
said um so with respect to the barbaric
people who engaged in this act I have no
sympathy
whatsoever nor should
anyone I
am
shocked but not surprised at the
celebration across the world that we
have seen of these attacks and this is a
predicament that we have been in many
times in the last few years shocked but
not surprised I believe I am morally
shocked to see people actually blind
themselves to what it is that they are
championing
is my inner being is shocked but my
analytical mind is not surprised because
as people who watch this podcast know
we have been talking about a incredible
growth in uh antisemitism and I don't
mean trumped up charges of
anti-Semitism I mean outright obvious
anti-Semitism right through uh the
rationalizing of Nazi
atrocities um we have seen a huge growth
in this in the last I've seen it in the
last year Gad sad has been talking about
it for a couple of years
um and so anyway to see it in the form
of people um chanting at the Sydney
Opera house or uh you know from The
River To The Sea uh in
Dearborn and you know in uh Toronto and
London and New York all of these places
where we have seen these people who do
not either do not care because they are
so their humanity is so fundamentally
broken or do not
register what it is that they are
celebrating I wonder I don't I don't
know that it matters but I wonder with
regard
to uh the
celebrations of the barbaric attack by
Hamas on Southern
Israel the celebrations in the streets
across the world I
wonder what percentage of those people
who are on the the street celebrating
actually saw what we saw on you know
videos on social media which is
unfortunately the source of
many much of what we think we
know and I don't see how you can get to
explaining away an entire crowd chanting
gas the
Jews but we've seen individual is on
camera proclaiming that Gaza should be
wiped off the map yep and we've seen
individuals on camera proclaiming that
Israel should be wiped off the map yeah
so individuals on both sides will
have abhorent
extremist um end of times you know end
times style beliefs for sure and
um and people are getting whipped into a
frenzy by forces that we cannot name
yet
but maybe it doesn't matter if the
people on the streets who were saying
finally Palestine is going to be free
don't know didn't see
the the war crimes of the young women
being paraded around abducted raped
killed right like it's it's classic war
crimes maybe they didn't
know but an entire crowd chanting I mean
gas to Jews is gas to
Jews there's no there's there's no
there's there's no amount of what did
they know what didn't they know that can
get to that being unacceptable I I don't
think we have to I don't think we have
to worry that they didn't see it and I
mean for one thing gas the Jews is gas
the Jews and from the river to the sea
is from The River To The Sea right these
are unambiguous and they are um
responsive to an Old Testament view of
the world in which um the displacement
will happen and the question is who will
be displaced not whether displacement
will
occur um so I would like to lay out what
I think is the fundamental principle
that divides the two sides and I want to
be very
careful I am not talking about two sides
in terms of
people anybody who wakes up to where we
are and joins the right side I would say
is welcome as long as they do it in good
faith so it's the sides that are right
and wrong it's not the people who are
fundamentally right or wrong though some
people have done unforgivable things
that's where Hamas
is the principle is this one
the
Western View in which we do not displace
other lineages
structurally we might out compete them
and they might out compete us but we do
not seek to hobble them in the
structures of society to BU a society in
the favor of lineages that
Viewpoint is
inconsistent with Notions of collective
guilt and
Punishment
and this is a much more difficult topic
than people understand for one thing I
would point out that the anti-semites
the real anti-semites that we see so
much of in recent times I mean at least
if you're looking in the right
place make this
error what they are saying is because of
EX Behavior which may or may not be real
that is being done by or has been done
by Jewish people that the Jews X the
Jews deserve X and my point would be
your your error is in imagining that the
presence of Jews in something abhorent
like the vaccine campaign that
surrounded coid the gaslighting of the
vaccine injured the establishment of
centralized Bank digital currencies that
are clearly designed to control Behavior
the presence of people from any
population in there does not indict all
members of that population that is Old
Testament thinking it is not consistent
with the values of the West which most
of the people shouting these out
anti-semitic things would in their
calmer moments say that they believed in
so it is the collective guilt that is
being imposed on a population and that
Collective guilt is wrong whether or not
you are committing it against Jews or
you are committing it against the entire
population of Gaza on the basis that
Gaza is in an Inseparable mix of people
who are guilty of this kind of thinking
and people who clearly are not and if
you don't think those people exist
consider that they are children so it is
I'm not arguing that we necessarily even
know how to operationalize a program in
which we do not end up inflicting
Collective punishment on people because
we can't separate them you've just had a
massive attack on Southern Israel and
Israel does not have surgical tools to
Simply deal with the people who are
connected and leave those who are not
connected unmolested I don't know what
Israel is supposed to do about that it
clearly is going to have to respond and
exactly um the way you would expect as
Hamas understood that it would when it
planned this attack
so I would just ask you all of you when
you're trying to figure out if somebody
is an anti-semite if somebody is making
a rational argument in terms of what the
response of Israel to the attack from
Gaza should be ask yourself the question
are they at least formally recognizing a
distinction between those who have
actually committed a crime
and those who are caught in the
crossfire and we must separate these
things it is as a formal matter at first
and as a practical matter as soon as we
can figure out how to do it but I want
to say one other thing before I let you
jump in the problem is that Collective
guilt and punishment is a morally
offensive
perspective but it is not without a
rational
explanation it'll be tempting to say
it's irrational to punish people for the
sins of their fathers the problem is the
reason that this concept exists and that
we have seen revivals of it in so many
different places is that of course it
works to punish somebody's descendants
and in fact one of the ways in which
terrorism is fostered is to promise to
enrich the families of those who commit
it that's how as one it's not the only
component but it is one of the
components that causes this to be a
wicked problem that we cannot shake well
that's that's exactly right
um liquidate a population and
redistribute their wealth to the
victors
it's as ancient as it's more ancient
than humans right any social longlived
organism uh that has territories that
has resources wherein resources are
limiting which means for
everyone
um is not driven primarily by hatred of
other the hatred of other comes after on
top it's a mechanism it is a mechanism
by which to take the things that other
has and the things include land include
food include women which have been a
resource of war and which we saw
um when in the US we woke up on the
morning of October 8th and um and saw
what had happened
um what's that seven was it the seventh
that we woke up to it um because they're
ahead of us yeah
um
so there are asymmetries
always but one of the asymmetries that
it's somehow
considered
icky to talk about is that the
redistribution redistribution of
wealth that would happen with the with
the outing of the Jews would be far
greater than the redistribution of
wealth um by the outing of the
Palestinians which um is not being
attempted anyway okay right and so I
also think that this is a moment to
review the types of Frontiers which we
talk about in the final chapter of hun
gatherers guide that this I mean this
is this is the illegitimate third
Frontier that we talk about type third
type of Frontier that we talk about and
this is this this is war this is what it
is so um I think that's a good idea and
we will review Frontiers here in just a
second but let me just say um
the
choice is
between
a Western View in which
collaboration is done irrespective of
lineage you collaborate with those who
are in a position to collaborate
productively with you which
produces a huge amount of wealth for
everybody involved that's why it's one
of the reasons it is so Superior when I
say Superior I'm not talking about uh
aesthetically it is safer it is
fairer it is uh more liberating it uh
it allows all of the best
characteristics of human beings to be
augmented my argument would be it is uh
fortunately stable under uh
circumstances where growth is possible
and in contraction the reverse happens
and that's where I believe we are in
history so let me just run through the
frontier thing if that's all right yeah
um so that uh people can just know the
language that you and I Ed to discuss
this Frontiers are growth opportunities
evolutionarily speaking this has nothing
to do with people creatures are in
search of Frontiers which is undere
exploited or unexploited opportunities
that they are positioned to utilize and
what happens is when they discover such
a thing their population grows in the
period in which it grows those are the
good times because there's literally
more than enough to go around and all it
takes to get it is work over in ecology
space we would tend to use the language
of Niche unexploited
undiscovered used Niche Niche right so
the first kind of Frontier is a
geographic Frontier imagine a creature
that swims across a channel and finds
itself on an island in which it Is Well
Suited ecologically and has no
competitors well that creature if it can
find a mate maybe well we could talk
about how that happens but that creature
if it can find uh a mate may be able to
beat The evolutionary odds by a
thousandfold you know leaving a
population behind whereas under normal
circumstances in a population that
wasn't growing it would only replace
itself um so that is a geographic
Frontier and Geographic Frontiers are
tremendous opportunities for a
population to experience growth and at
least in English and I assume all
languages honestly uh when you say
Frontier it is the geographic Frontier
that the Mind goes to that is what
people assume you're talking about yep
but people have talked metaphorically
about the next kind of Frontier rather
regularly yes which is a techn olical
Frontier technological Frontier is one
in which you don't find any new
territory but you figure out some way to
utilize your territory so that is as if
you have found more territory and the
obvious example would be the transition
from hunting and Gathering to farming
which can support a great deal larger
population on the same patch of
territory if the territory is hospitable
to farming and and it's and it's fractal
So within farming how is it that you
take advantage of steep slopes well you
invent terracing and suddenly landscaper
you knew how to farm but you couldn't
keep the seeds in place the runoff was
too much suddenly you can make um aable
land out of land that was untenable yep
and then you've got crop rotation and so
many uh all sorts of technology so and
each of these constitutes an as if
discovery of new territory and the point
is it creates a temporary period in
which people are effectively wealthy
because there's more resource than they
are utilizing it's the good times and
then the population bumps up against
some new what we call carrying capacity
which is the limit of how big a
population that Niche can support so and
you therefore will have um boom and bust
Cycles the boom Cycles being dependent
on new technological Frontiers right
which can be closely spaced you can have
a period in which Frontier after
Frontier and then you can have which
looks like perennial growth right and it
creates this fantasy that technology can
create permanent growth which is how we
got ourselves into this terrible mess in
the the first place but okay so you've
got Geographic Frontiers you've got
technological Frontiers when the
technological Frontiers run out imagine
for a moment that humans as a special
case of what's true for all creatures
are addicted to growth the reason that
they are addicted to growth is because
it causes them to pursue every
opportunity that might be a growth
opportunity and that means when they are
starved for growth they effectively end
up
jonesing and the jonesing population
is a dangerous population because there
is a way without creating any growth
without increasing the size of the pie
there is a way to bring your
population something that tastes an
awful lot like growth and that is to
steal what somebody else has that they
can't defend right this is a transfer of
wealth
Frontier and the point is it's not a
real Frontier because the pie actually
shrinks if you make war in your neighbor
and you steal their land then what
you're doing is not
discovering some enlightened way of
getting more from the world either by
finding a new land mass or some new way
of doing stuff you're just stealing it
depends on the scope of your view right
it feels like a frontier to you well um
and so a geographic Frontier uh might
well be Global a technological Frontier
might well be Global uh good for
everyone who finds such a thing um but a
transfer of wealth or transfer of
resource Frontier is
inherently um positive for someone to
someone else's negative experience right
and so anyway in our book the final
punchline to this
is technological front Geographic
Frontiers were done we found them all
until we get to some other planet and
we're a long way from doing that in any
useful fashion technological Frontiers
there will be more of them um but you
cannot rely on them they do not come
regularly spaced enough to keep us from
descending into this third Frontier
which we must avoid this Old Testament
uh lineage against lineage uh transfer
of resource Frontier because what it
looks like is war and genocide which is
what history looks like and the
technological Frontiers often come with
downsides that uh we can't predict in
advance quite so the argument that we
make and we're not going to explore it
deeply here is that there is actually
another possibility at least
theoretically which is to create
circumstances that give the human beings
the sensation of growth and I don't mean
fooling them but I mean giving them the
sensation of grow grow so that the
triggers that cause them to flip into
that lineage against lineage genocidal
Warfare making uh mindset do not get
triggered and this do this is not some
fantasy it's not utopian any more than
the idea that you could have a house in
which the temperature is always
spring-like on the inside we do have
those houses and the fact is we do this
through perfectly mundane means that
cause us to you know arbitrarily dump
heat into our backyard to keep the
building cool it's not a violation of
physics right the physics held but from
the point of view on the inside of the
building it's nice and pleasant um so
there's a question about whether or not
we could architect a stable steady state
that did not trigger people to become uh
genocidal
which uh we believe is the inevitable
outgrowth of just simply allowing the
system of Frontiers to run its course
with the EB and flow of technological
things so anyway not to over
intellectualize a situation that is
simply um composed of barbarism and
tragedy but at some level the real
question
is if you care about the
barbarism you want to see the barbarism
Stamped Out
forever
then the question is what is forcing us
back into that mode and it could be that
it is just simple the normal turning of
history or it could be that cynical
forces are attempting to
thwart the success of the
alternative mode and unfortunately
recent history gives us an awful lot of
evidence that something is working
against our ability to complete the
project of the West which was it was a
prototype we never got to a place where
lineage didn't matter at all we never
got there but we certainly did know that
that was the direction to head and there
was a time in the very recent past where
effectively we all knew it and we have
lost touch with that and
so
um that is in some sense what the
podcast that ephrat and I did yesterday
was about was looking at this
um this tragedy that occurred in Israel
and asking questions that are so
painfully obvious that it cannot be the
conscious mind it cannot be the values
that we claim to hold that would
actually block us from asking them why
why
was arguably the most defended border on
Earth
undefended on the anniversary of a
historical attack on Israel the yam
kipor War to the extent that Hamas was
able to breach that border in many
places
simultaneously and bring a large Force
into the country that uh operated nearly
unopposed for many many hours that is a
question that a rational person would
have have to ask and maybe it has a
perfectly M mundane explanation but the
problem is if you search for that
mundane explanation it does not suggest
itself this was such a failure
that one has to bend over backwards to
rescue the idea that it was
organic so I don't know what that means
there are lots of ways it could be
inorganic but the lack of Interest
apparently in figuring out which of
those
actually explains it is troubling in and
of
itself well it's it's reminiscent of
three and a half years ago of course um
as as Co broke and uh schools and
businesses were closed and lockdowns
ensued and uh the CDC and The Who and in
the US the IH then the IAD with fouchy
at the helm and such um just started
putting in place things that didn't make
sense over and over and over
again thought W how how could it be this
wrong right what are what are the
chances and this is something that we
weren't saying then but we started
saying soon
thereafter it's one thing to have to
come up with a lot of pronouncements or
a lot of action and make errors it is
this is both complex and complicated and
there will be errors uh even if um the
people who are supposedly looking out
for us are actually uh competent and
doing their
best however at the point that nearly
every response is the opposite of what
turns out to be true or should have been
done that is no longer something that
would have happened by
chance so it raises question
how could it be a set of responses that
are extraordinarily unlikely to have
happened by
chance and this is both an entirely
different situation and yet it raises
for me the the hardly ghosts they're not
dead we're still living uh in a world in
which many of us have come to be aware
of how much more broken even the systems
that we knew were broken are but I guess
the question is what does broken
mean a system might be
broken uh if it can't do what it is
trying to do because the world has
become again perhaps more complex or
even just more complicated than the
system can handle or a system might be
broken in which it is uh and here I am
borrowing I don't remember from whom
effectively a skin suit of
itself where it still appears to be the
thing that it was in which we had our
trust uh for for instance scientists in
the US NSF and NIH for many who have
ever before considered public health the
CDC the who the United States
government if those things are not
actually what they used to be but they
still wear the label if they still have
the skin suit then broken isn't
broken it's only broken according to
what we think what we still believe
these systems are Civ suppos to be doing
yeah yeah it's a feature not a bug
question is this the bug ification of
everything or are these features to some
Undeclared system right that read as
bugs to us because we can't imagine the
level of dysfunction and skull dugery uh
would be anything other
than um natural it's it's an almost an
unthinkable thought and so let me right
and therefore easy to dismiss right and
I think um one of you says in the
podcast You released yesterday you know
actually a fan of the idea of conspiracy
uh theorist I think I think one of you
says this in yesterday's uh podcast the
question is because if you know if if
you actually think that no conspiracy
ever
happens what are you
doing yeah it's it first of all I mean
we just simply know that they happen and
so any any epistemology that declares
them fictional uh uh is
inherently um wrong um sorry I was
looking something
up
the we are being asked not to register
the level of dysfunction and we are also
being asked to focus on one crisis at a
time which if rot correctly points out
is part of the silification that causes
us not to see the anomalies that exist
between topics well I guess I would um I
didn't hear in your conversation
yesterday a we are being asked to focus
only on one thing at a time it you know
when when something extraordinary
happens you know many of us will will
pivot uh but I don't know I think that
is just part
of human nature we we both we get we get
both overwhelmed and and full and some
you know some some new crisis comes and
some number of us like I just I can't I
I just don't know enough and I'm focused
over here and I I can't do that now
right I can't become expert enough to
say anything about that thing now it's a
natural reaction you know people have uh
wisely discovered that multitasking
isn't a real thing right that it's to
the extent that you do it you do it a
great consequence negative consequence
your ability to do either of the tasks
well this is the same idea cognitively
it's hard to pay attention to multiple
things at once but here's what happens
if you don't I'm not saying you can pay
attention well to two things at once but
you can pay attention to the The Meta
pattern in other words you can zoom out
yes and you can say for example in this
case here is something that I register
as a meta
anomaly we are being asked to
accept
that the Israeli military and
intelligence
complex
aired so
massively as to allow this
incredible breach of this border that
apparently according to a captured Hamas
operative shocked even them they did not
expect to be able to do this now I don't
know if that's true or not it could be
propaganda who knows but we are being
asked to accept that there is some
organic explanation and that we are
furiously trying to figure out what it
might be when that extends well beyond
any plause ible failure and I will
defend that in a second if I need to but
superficially to say if that failure is
beyond what an organic failure could
produce
plausibly then the question
is has something gotten into the Israeli
system that is ready to
sacrifice civilians or some other
purpose that has not been named and we
do not know now that's an incredible
thought it's a terrible thought on the
other
hand if you look at what Israel did
during coid right the entire population
was
betrayed Israel had amongst the highest
vaccination rates of any country on
Earth that was the result of whatever it
is that controls the Israeli system of
government inflicting un necessary harm
on the population of Israel I don't know
what to make of it but the fact that you
have two historical events that appear
to have nothing to do with each other
that share the characteristic of looking
like something that must
go beyond the level of organic failure
both of which involve something in
control that has asymmetrical access to
information putting the population of
citizens in Jeopardy of terrible things
and then not telling the truth about it
right and again I think um you know
massive unprecedented error I would say
that error there is doing the same job
as broken in what I was talking about
earlier that error and broken uh can
mean two totally different things you
know perhaps everyone involved is
actually overwhelmed with with grief and
a desire that this never ever ever
happen again because the system is what
it appears to be and it is the thing
that it came to be under normal
circumstances
or perhaps there are those who have
helped to make things happen who are
benefiting um right and if this were a
simple organic failure then across the
board we would be expecting to see
people trying to figure out what it was
because the chances I mean did Hamas get
into the military and
uh and
intelligence did it compromise Israeli
military intent and intelligence and
Cause th this breach that would
certainly be a question you would want
I'm not saying it happened I don't think
it did but you would want to rule it out
because something Beyond normal has to
explain this and let me just again I you
know the point about conspiracy theory
is this if you're really if you really
believe that the idea that a hypothesis
alleges a possible
conspiracy is invalidating on its face
then you're not paying attention we have
all kinds of collusion taking place and
the harm to the public if you if you
didn't notice it over coid then you
really got to go back and review what
happened there was an awful lot of
collusion to keep us in the dark to
cause us to do things that were actually
not in our interest to fail to register
opportunities to protect certain
populations like young people from
dangerous things like so-called vaccines
from which they get no benefit and
attempt to memory hole all of that by
the same players who tried to try who
effectively demonized uh those of us who
were resistant in the first place
anybody who's paying attention can see
it and so the point is really not are
you a conspiracy theorist or not the
question is are you any good at it right
are you good at being rigorous in the
confusing landscape where collusion may
be taking place can you avoid seeing uh
ghosts where they're not you know and
it's not easy because frankly um the
nature of conspiracy is to create a
phony story which then causes aam's
razor to trigger artificially right so
how do you tell the difference between
an organically simple explanation for
something and a phony baloney simple
explanation that effectively obscures
the truth that's that's the difficulty
philosophically and how do you do it
when all of the emotional Tri are on
high it's even more difficult right it's
that if we can get you you're scared for
your life maybe because it's a virus
maybe because it's barbaric terrorists
but either way you're scared for your
life and fear is running your decision
making apparatus and it is affecting
your ability to see what might be true
right it is by putting your by forcing
your amydala into a control position you
can sideline your conscious mind and
somebody the question is is somebody
doing that because we will lose all of
our best tools for all of the stuff that
we as humans are capable of doing uh in
a calmer
mindset so let me lay out a couple
couple pieces here one let us just
simply talk about the level of failure
of what took place on the Gaza
border um we are told that the force
that was supposed to be there and did
not show up uh uh in significant numbers
uh for many hours had actually been
moved this is something uh afrat calls
our attention to that they' been moved
on the 50th anniversary of the OM kipur
War which is a strange choice because of
course symbolically speaking that would
be a moment at which you would have to
imagine at least some extra danger over
your average
day
um but let's imagine that somebody made
an argument inside of Israeli
uh defense circles that in fact in this
case the necessity of that force was
greater at a remote location and that
they needed to be pulled from the
border I cannot
imagine that some person would not have
stood up and
said that can't possibly be right
because at the very least we can't be
totally certain of what our enemy is
able to detect of our
movements maybe Hamas you know Hamas is
connected to other nations with
intelligence Services who's to say what
they know and so at the moment that you
argue to pull your force from the border
that it protects it may be that you are
sending your enemy a message that this
is a good time to attack
because defense will never be more
absent and so inherently if you were
going to pull some large fraction action
of that Force to somewhere else you
would leave another force in its place
you would leave half of that Force there
in an activated form you would do
something but you wouldn't just pull
them away because of some superficial
need which may be very real somewhere
else that doesn't make any sense and so
so we are left with a paradox which is
behavior that appears to extend beyond
incompetence which is the exact pattern
that we saw during Co it was behav avors
that were are still being dismissed as
incompetent but can't be incompetent
because it's not plausible that level of
incompetence is implausible and so I
think can you look
up uh hanlin's
razor will Wikipedia suffice for this I
think for this it'll work we don't
recommend
Wikipedia it's an addage or rule of
thumb that states handland razor never
attribute to malice that with which is
adequately explained by stupidity okay
I'm going to argue that we
are um living Downstream of this
appalling principle that this principle
is in fact a weapon of War maybe it was
not formulated that way but it is
functioning that way and my point is
going to be handland razor
is a false
corollary
of um of of aams Razer now aam Razer is
not a perfect principle in part because
it's an ancient principle and it needs a
little updating aams Razer Loosely
states that the simplest explanation for
a set of observations tends to be
correct all other things being equal all
other things being equal and um I would
argue that the proper reformulation of
aam's Razer so that it becomes a rock
solid principle is given perfect
information given perfect and complete
information the simplest explanation is
always
true um and that we never have perfect
and complete information so the point is
we have to downregulate it to is
generally
true um but the problem is hanlin's
Razor is not a razor aam's razor is
actually a surgically precise if
properly instan instantiated a
surgically precise and operational
framework for reason
mhm handlings razor masquerades As a
Razor but not only is it not a razor
it's not even a hand axe it's it's a
sledgehammer and the idea is that it is
used to silence anybody who starts
putting two and two together and seeing
evidence of collusion and I am hear me
clearly I am not saying that if you
applied handland razor you won't be
right 95% of the time you will be in
general there's a lot of incompetence
out there and it explains a lot of
broken stuff well and as with so many of
these things it really depends on both
where you're standing and what your
scope of view is and so you can say
about one thing that you see now it
can't have been it's very unlikely to
have been malice it's probably stupidity
um but you go farther and farther back
in either space or time and you see more
and more of the things and if you're
just finding stupidity everywhere and
there's one thing that could be making
it happen you have to start thinking
that there is something potentially
malicious as opposed to Simply
incompetent because stupidity is a kind
of incompetence and Malice is a kind of
intelligence right like malice requires
uh at least across large scales not just
intelligence but a kind of organization
so you know malice is standing in for
conspiracy here and stupidity is
standing in for um incompetence and
therefore to some degree chance and this
you know this is consistent with like oh
most people are stupid like you know
what
um most people are
convincible of things that aren't true
but actually the level of stupidity is a
lot lower than people attribute uh and
uh though it may be rising but in any
case here's my point when is it really
important that you not
apply Handlin so-called razor actual
Sledgehammer in the 5% of cases
where actually what you're looking at
can't be explained by incompetence and
so what it does is it puts in the hand
of people who have no demonstrated
capacity to sort between instances in
which incompetence has created a failure
versus something like sabotage it puts
in their hands a way of silencing those
who would explore the
question so that is not something you
want alive in the world right to
recognize you know if you rephrased it
so that it was actually a proper uh
claim you know um something like
incompetence often explains that which
we are tempted to uh ascribe to
malevolence something like that okay
that's true then we don't you know but
what the is the word never doing
there and when did we all take a class
on what can be right the point
is you have to have a standard in order
to wield that in any useful way if
you're going to have a never then you
have to have a rock solid standard a
threshold in which you can say in this
case we don't see enough evidence of
something uh unusual to really say that
we are outside the bounds of uh what can
be explained by incompetence the level
of incompetence that it would take for
um is it the most modern military on
Earth certainly one of the top few is it
the most sophisticated intelligence
service on Earth certainly one of the
top few what would it take for that
combination I mean in addition it's not
like um the rest of the sophisticated
intelligence organizations around the
world it's not as if you know the US
doesn't view its interests as tied up in
events in the Middle East the US didn't
notice Hamas for a year practicing and
building for this operation nobody
noticed and now they're telling us that
they are surgically attacking the
installations that Hamas uses to conduct
its operations we know where those
things are but we didn't know that there
was an operation being planned and they
pulled the the force off the border and
crossed their fingers on the anniversary
of the Yum Kapur war look maybe there's
a great explanation for how this
happened but it is the lack of curiosity
about the oddness of that pattern that
really tells the story I suspect
yeah it is also of course true that
malice uh malicious intent will be more
successful If part of what it does if
one of its uh methods is to increase
incompetence such that there are fewer
individuals around uh to notice what is
happening uh to say wait a minute uh to
you know to in any way uh deflect or
resist uh the things that are happening
and I have no idea about um the IDF but
certainly in the us we see I believe we
see both things in the US military right
um you know it has been ever harder uh
to attract people uh according to the
old
standards uh and you have the
feminization of the military uh through
various means and all of that is
distracting a whole bunch of people
while who knows what kind of cover that
gives uh to the other things that are
happen happening which brings me to the
next facet of this which is something
I'm horrified to be watching but this
turn of events historical and whatever
their nature let's say that they're
perfectly organic that what took place
is exactly what it appears to be a
massive intelligence and Military
failure in Iran a Iran in Israel a uh uh
cleverly uh planned utterly barbaric
attack by Hamas designed to produce a
massive reaction that will curry
sympathy in the world whatever let's say
it's exactly what it appears to be
um
the consequence of it outside of the
Middle
East is to make conversations that were
taking place a week ago very difficult
to have if not impossible now and what I
would point to is is that there is a
this has been quite true across multiple
events in recent history there's
something that I would call the
Coalition slicer dicer working on us and
what it does let's say that you have a
group of people who have found each
other and they have come to understand
how to interact with each other and they
have established bonds of trust over
their growing sense making surrounding
Co right you have the dissidents who are
realizing that they're all seeing pieces
of the puzzle and then they pull those
pieces and they say oh my God here's
what the larger puzzle looks like and
they are empowered and they hold
meetings and they become uh an
important uh force on the landscape
because as the population wakes up to
the fact that something was done to it
um that was
Unholy these people have all been seen
to offer pieces of the truth along the
way that is a very powerful force that
force is fiercely divided over the
interpretation of what took place on
October 7th in Israel to the point that
it can no longer move in a coordinated
Direction
because the tensions over the current uh
thing are such that um it has
forgotten what it understood about the
the bonds of trust that were necessary
for that to function are um strained to
the breaking point and that is not the
first time it's happened when it
happened with coid if we step back one
phase into this um landscape of
heterodoxy Co absolutely divided the
Coalition that had formed around the
danger of the woke Revolution the woke
Revolution brought a great many people
together it caused those same bonds to
form people were actually an important
force in the world pushing back on this
woke narrative calling out ESG and all
of those things that was devastated by
Co those who could not see past the
mainstream perspective on coid um took a
different path and so that heterodox
world was sliced right down the middle
and we've now seen it happen again and
this has impacts across the globe it has
impacts on the US presidential election
it has impacts on our understanding of
us entanglements uh abroad
generally and my concern is you know uh
divide and conquer is a famously ancient
strategy uh my guess is we would find uh
the formulation of it in many different
Traditions obviously Napoleon knew about
it shly sunzoo is going to have things
to say about it um but divide and
conquer in an information landscape
might look very much like
a um an ongoing slicer dicer operation
that simply tears coalitions apart so
that they are never capable of making
any meaningful change which is after all
I think the the Goliath's purpose
frustrating meaningful change so that
Goliath retains the control that he has
engineered for himself is um is the
point and so in any case there again
stepping back to the meta level yes you
have this absolutely unignorable real
phenomenon involving life and limb and
absolute unignorable barbarism taking
place really on the ground amongst real
people that is very difficult for a
human being to step back from and try to
place in any sort of context because
that almost feels
disrespectful but the fact is that
larger context to the extent that there
is some um aoral entity that might be
commandeering our government structures
and causing them to act against our
interests as Citizens that it might be
shaping world events to uh fuel the time
traveling money printer and uh you know
and make its black budget flush with
money whatever it might be doing we
would be fools not to recognize that at
the very least the following two things
are true there are people who get rich
when human beings need
weapons okay there are people who have a
perverse incentive that their business
interests caus them to view peace and
war with an inverse veilance of what a
normal person would see that is true
it's surely also true that there are
people who profit from sickness who view
sickness and health also with an inverse
veence because their business is
treating people who are sick
so if such forces exist and if we do not
live in a world free of corruption we
have to
ask to the extent that things seem to
defy an explanation based on normal
incompetence is somebody else
driving and are they doing so because
they have a perverse interest and a
great deal more power than any rational
society would give
them I think that's um
yeah I I don't know what else you have
planned but that seems like that seems
like the culminating thought right that
we know every
everyone
everyone knows
that there are people who win when we
are at War and there are people who win
when we are
sick imagine what you will about why
individuals got into the
into the business that they did but
weapons manufacturing and pharmaceutical
companies as frankly at at one level
sort of the the shallow the obvious end
of the pool which doesn't make sense as
a metaphor but um you can simply point
to they will win when you aren't doing
as well as you want to be
doing yes that's not that that sentence
could be reframed as a
conspiracy right right it's simply true
it's obvious it's obvious it's simply
true we are humans we are social we come
together over shared interests sometimes
needs things that come to be shared
because of how we have ended up in
places and if you end up being someone
who wins when the world is in
Conflict you are not going to be
interested in having the rest of us
figure out how to get rid of the
conflict I want to add two last thoughts
and then I think it is a it is a proper
place to to wrap this
up one thought is
that a week ago we were stuck in a
predicament where some of us were seeing
um an appalling
uptick in anti-Semitism and of a very
disquieting kind not just the standard
tropes but also people who I consider
reasonable on the average day accounts
that I've known for years people who
have defended me and others in
circumstances uh where they felt it
necessary
experimenting with anti-Semitism they
don't even think they I don't even think
they know they're doing it in many cases
but experimenting and what do I mean by
anti-Semitism am I seeing Phantoms no
I'm talking about people who violate the
principle that I laid out at the
beginning of this podcast which is they
are toying with the tropes of collective
punishment and guilt that is to say what
can we say of the Jews and the answer is
next to nothing because the Jews is a
large lineage it is composed of many
sublineages it stends back into history
thousands of years across multiple
languages there's generalizing as a
Fool's Paradise um but I do believe that
one of the things that I've seen I've
seen the slicing dicing thing that we
just and it is most disturbing because
it it really is going to prevent us from
uh making any useful progress against
that which threatens us all um but I
have also seen many people who I think
were agnostic on the question of whether
or not there was anti-Semitism a foot in
some new way or whether we were
imagining it or whether that was you
know the ADL uh shaking people down or
whatever which it may well be but um
that's not what some of us were seeing
some of us were seeing seeing a genuine
uptick and maybe that's because we
stumbled into a place where it was
taking place all along uh and so it's
our awareness that has taken an uptick
but it's also quite likely especially in
light of how many people's position has
moved in this direction that it's just a
simple genuine uptick and one
frankly uh my work on lineage selection
has predicted for 20 years right the the
contraction of our economy will trigger
this uptake and anti-Semitism for
reasons I've explained elsewhere I
believe that what we've seen people
chanting the Jews and gas the Jews
in Australia from The River To The Sea
and Dearborn all of these uh unambiguous
celebrations of barbarism against Jews
caused a lot of people who I think were
straddling a certain fence to wake up
and see that actually this thing is real
and it is much more broads spread or
widespread than they uh had expected and
so I am hoping that at least we could
can stop having that mind-numbing
discussion and maybe some of the people
who were experimenting with thoughts in
this direction will also wake up to what
it is that they were becoming party to I
think that would be perfectly natural
many of us on the left at some point had
to wake up to what kinds of messages
were circulating on the left and
recognize uh actually these are not my
people I don't know what they're talking
about but they're Reviving racism of
many different kinds that has nothing to
do with any value I want any part of and
this is that same thing that
anti-Semitism thing is a feature of the
landscape people have been way too
comfortable with it and it is time for
people to recognize it's real and we
know where it goes you don't want to
live through that whether you're Jewish
or not we cannot afford to have that
thing happen um again yeah now let me
just say the the the the reprehensible
responses
uh anti-israel responses to the
barbarism that that happened on October
7th um are an effect a downstream effect
of things like the progressive stack you
know the progressive stack uh which says
uh you don't get to talk in this meeting
at this activist event at this protest
um until all the people with more points
against them who are whose populations
have been more oppressed um have had
their say first that is an Insidious and
insane Rule and when you see people at
the Sydney Opera house uh chanting gas
the Jews that is one of the things
that's Downstream yeah okay
um last Point uh or it's a couple points
tied together um ifrat uh was challenged
rather directly by a couple of different
people including one person who uh I
apparently know from the conference in
bath which is where I first met ifra
brought um the co conference Co
dissidence in in bath a couple years ago
um and this person challenged her it was
a very strange bit of push back it was
very personal want me to show it
appeared to um I don't know I'm not sure
I want to amplify it but it
appeared uh this person is somebody who
had been aligned with if frat and had
been a friend and they have had a
falling out and this person leveled uh
charges that I think carry no water
effectively the charge is that if frat
was misrepresenting herself as expert in
things and I think it will be very clear
to anybody who listens to the podcast
that if rot has simply portrayed what
her expertise is she said she was in the
IDF 25 years ago she spent one day a
week uh Sitting On the Border as an
observer and the rest in intelligence
you can judge for yourself how relevant
that experience is to a modern attack on
that border but it wasn't like it was
being obscured so um I do think that in
some sense what what we did with that
podcast was we violated a rule that is
sacred to one party that because we
talked about this in analytical and
hopefully careful terms that we got in
the way of a program to accomplish
something and it is those people driving
a program to accomplish something
that threatened to drag uh the Middle
East and perhaps the entire world back
into the Old Testament set of rules
which I with modern technology is not
something that we will
survive the rule that you
broke uh was engaging in
speculation uh that is I didn't say that
well the rule that you broke was you
shall not say anything about which you
are not 100% confident well this person
and
and we saw this also during coid right
and you know part part of the objections
to what was happening during coid was no
they're saying things that couldn't
possibly be true right they have no way
of knowing that these products are safe
and are safe just stick with safe they
they cannot know that given the time
period um for which they've been out
therefore if they are saying that what
else are they saying that they can't
possibly know or that they know isn't
true right um but there's the idea that
you shall not say anything about which
you do not have complete proof is is is
is an absurd rule so long as you are
clear when you are engaging in
speculation and you two in that
conversation were extraordinarily clear
I believe we were clear I would also
point out that this this account uh that
came after ifrat specifically said the
com the to the extent the complaint was
specific she said that um she the person
leveling the charge prefers to work from
research and documents she specifically
mentions and that if FR uh has taken to
looking at other kinds of evidence and
uh extrapolating from it now in a
perfect world where you had access to
all the documents right away sure um but
imagine in this case what that rule does
to
us the documents that explain the
failure of the IDF to defend the Israeli
population on the Gaza
border if we get to see those documents
at all it could be years down the road
World War could have started as a result
of what takes place in the Middle East
over the next couple of months before we
ever get a chance to look at those
documents and we may never get a chance
to look at those documents nor would you
be able to take them at face value if
you did that is the problem of the
modern era where we are we have called
it here the fog machine of War before
which means the fog is intentional
they're creating a situation in which we
cannot figure out what is true and that
is not on us but you cannot ask us not
to notice obvious anomalies and attempt
to figure out what they mean this is
what this is what human beings do this
is how human beings upgrade their
software they find anomalies and they
struggle to understand what could
possibly explain them and when they
succeed they do so through a pattern of
hypothesizing making predictions and
then discovering that those predictions
are either true or false this is the
natural order of people left with a
difficult puzzle to sort out and it is
to ask people not to do it is an
absurdity especially given how much the
world has at stake in this particular
situation okay the final thing I will
say is that among the problems of the
slicer dicer program that I see
operating breaking coalitions is a great
many people who have what I would call a
deal breaker circuit and I have a few of
these deal breaker circuits myself um
barbarism is a deal breaker for me right
you can't rescue yourself from having
engaged in barbarism that is to say
inflicting uh torment on people
intentionally for tactical
reasons
the dealbreaker circuits though are set
on a hair trigger for many people so
lots of people heard um Bobby Kennedy
appear to want to commit the US to a
military
entanglement uh with respect to Israel's
defense against Hamas and that for them
was a deal breaker now I think
committing the US to a uh an
entanglement is a mistake I I don't
think we know enough about what happened
or what our interests are and I just
think that was an error on the other
hand the real question is how are we
going to regain enough influence over
our system that we can navigate in a
direction that serves the public in that
landscape you do not want deal breakers
that cause you to abandon what may well
be your best hope of having you know
high levels of
nuance uh dominate the conversation
about our interests that take place at
the highest uh echelons of power
so don't let them slice us and dice us
and triggle Trigger your deal breakers
so that you're constantly throwing
people overboard because they've said
that thing they mustn't have said
they've signed up on the side of that uh
that uh conflict that has you know no
Humanity to it right if they've signed
up with barbaric people yeah that's true
right but that's not where we are with
most of these things we have to get less
hair trigger and we have to see more
broadly long term there aren't very many
solutions to the problem of wholesale
capture of all of our institutions which
you know if you don't know what I'm
talking about I'm not talking to you but
if you do know that all of our
institutions have been captured and that
there that our well-being absolutely
requires that we do something about that
and the number of things that one could
conceivably do about it is very very few
then the answer is you understand
that the chessboard is a very
constrained place it's not a place for
hair trigger decisionmaking and so I
would ask everyone to think all of the
levels at which each of these crises
function who might be driving and why
and what do they think you're going to
do if they knew that you were going to
lose the ability to trust people that
last week you trusted and they triggered
this with that in mind then you would be
wise not to behave as they expect you to
behave because they did it because um
they basically transferred well-being
from you to them so we have to stop
behaving predictably and we have to stay
out of our amigdalas and that's really
really tough in an era where we have
absolute barbarism taking place on our
screens being celebrated across the
globe but um you know think about think
about what when we when we uh train
people for Special
Forces I maybe Special Forces people
will correct this but I'm pretty sure of
it one of the key jobs is to take people
ordinary humans who will ordinarily
react to terrifying situations with not
their full
toolkit and to put them through
situations so that they learn to become
careful and able to reason Under Fire
under the worst possible circumstances
and that is why those Elite forces are
um capable of doing what they do now I'm
not saying Elite forces are always doing
the right thing obviously they do
whatever the chain of command tells them
to do but we have to get good at not
being Marshal around the chessboard by
being uh triggered by events whose
explanation we cannot understand
very
good
um we'll be back in a few short days all
right we have another live stream on
Saturday at 11:30 Pacific and another
one on after that on Tuesday at 11:30
a.m. Pacific we have a private Q&A uh at
our locals uh at 11: on Sunday uh so
lots more opportunities to find us and
then um and then and then we break for
for a short time in the meantime you can
find us all the usual places uh I think
I'm not going to go through um all of
them right now um we will we'll spend a
little bit more time on that on
Saturday um reminder of our sponsors
this week arra MD hearing and American
Hartford gold you'll be able to find
links to those um offers in the show
notes uh as well as uh a link to that
article that you wrote in the wake of
the Charlie HDO um
no not bombing shoot Mass yeah Massacre
um in Paris in 2015
something
um we are supported by you we appreciate
you subscribing and liking and sharing
um full episodes Clips uh as Brett
suggested at the beginning um consider
um checking out the
Darkhorse
Twitter account yep uh and and also our
our account at Rumble and locals and
until we see you next time please be
good to the ones you love eat good food
and get outside thanks for joining
[Music]
us